harry styles just put on a dress
harry styles word dress i don't even
really know who harry styles is i kind
of recognize the name
what is he a singer or an actor or
something like that he's some show
business guy
and he takes this picture wearing a very
silly dress
but as far as i can tell he's not
wearing the dress ironically he's
wearing the dress
earnestly and candace owens
my friend and now colleague candace
owens tweets out
there is no society that can survive
without strong men the east knows this
and the west
the steady feminization of our men at
the same time that marxism is being
taught to our children
is not a coincidence it's an outright
right attack bring back manly men and
she trends for this on twitter
people were so upset that she said this
how dare you suggest that harry styles
can't wear a dress now
some people on the right the more
libertarian right get this wrong they
say who cares if he wears a dress it has
nothing to do with me
has nothing to do with culture you know
it doesn't have to do with politics
first of all
yes it does yes it does we need to stop
this silly thing that everybody can do
whatever they want to do and that has no
political or cultural effect at all
first of all it obviously has a cultural
effect
if men start wearing dresses that is a
description of culture
what is culturing it involves our
cultivation it involves how we behave
in the world right now men wear suits
a little bit at least they wear suits
that's just a cultural norm
men i guess could wear dresses but that
would be a different culture
but moreover it is political politics
is just how we all get along together
that i know we have a very narrow
definition of politics now to
just what certain departments of the
government do but that's not
historically what politics is
and i think conservatives are very silly
to adopt this narrow view of politics
politics is just how we all get along
together so obviously culture affects
politics
politics affects culture it's a little
bit of a blurry line
and it is political when a public figure
does something
in public that is a political statement
and the political statement here is
that men ought to wear dresses and it's
something the right doesn't get either
because
sometimes the right either gets too
permissive or too moralizing about this
and the real answer is somewhere in the
middle
i can't believe i even have to say this
it's so so
weird that our culture is decayed so
much that i have to say this obvious
truth
men wearing dresses dressing in drag is
funny
because men are not supposed to wear
dresses
it is funny i know some people want to
really moralize and say drag isn't funny
it's
merely an abomination it's merely that
okay but it is kind of funny it's funny
because it's incongruous
because men are not supposed to wear
dresses but you need that second part
for it to be funny too
if you live in a world where you think
men are supposed to wear dresses then
it's not funny
right this is something the left managed
to do they somehow managed to make drag
queens boring i don't know how you do
that
they somehow managed to make these crazy
insane parades there's a parade in in
new york on coney island i think it's
called the mermaid parade and it's where
all these drag queens dress up in crazy
costumes and it's very weird you know
that's whole point of it is it's
supposed to be weird
now we're supposed to be told this is
entirely normal but it's not normal men
are not in dresses
the fact that a man
can put on all of the various
accoutrements and adornments
of womanhood of femininity and still be
obviously a man is what makes it funny
because it means that there is such a
thing as masculinity there is such a
thing as manliness
you can dress it all up like a woman but
still
you're a man well we've lost sight of
that now because we believe that men can
be women and women can be men and
genders a social construct
and sex isn't real even though it's
innate and our sexual dispositions are
so innate we can't change them
we're born this way obviously there's so
many contradictions here
there's no such thing as gender but
women are the future the future is
female he said wait a second what
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you